welcome back to the Rich Eisen show not
just to the listeners and viewers but to
the man sitting to my right he was here
in November now he is back he is about
to take on Yoel Romero it is the
happening up coming up on in on March
the 7th in t-mobile
Arena of the man is gonna be taking on
his first undisputed title fight he is
none other than the current undisputed
UFC middleweight champion of the world
Israel Auto Sanya good to see you sir
I've been good at being gravy baby yeah
living now you've got the belt with you
right here as always
you do job do you travel around with it
is it got so much it's heavy but we have
people to travel with it I can do
appearances like this yeah bags of his
own does it had some sleeve but um my
one I've got a case for it because you
know I feel like it's a privilege to be
able to handle this and yeah a lot of
people were handling it after I won it
so I felt like it needs a briefcase and
looks cooler as well like I'm a secret
agent like an the men in black or
something yes and it's just you just
walk around with it and most business
men must be a large briefcase or
something like this do we know how much
this costs how much is it's worth do we
know how much Dana Dana make it a little
bit more more I see what yeah of course
man I might even make it a spinner like
John Cena how he did it with his WWE
bill and it's still spinning I might
bring that back Oh we'll see I love it I
love it how has life changed for you me
and life since the last time I saw you
same book different same same but
different just a little bit more
notoriety but you know I keep the same
energy I'm just I'm just enjoying me
right but I just in terms of is this the
way you wanted it to work out this is
how I envisioned everything this is how
I've seen it for me I've always kind of
um being ready for fame I've always
prepared for it because a lot of people
were in my position get thrust into the
spotlight and then they're just like
deer in the headlights they don't know
how to act or what's doing yeah you see
them get built up they rise and in the
world just watches them fall I've seen
in entertainment and sports yes in this
you know in this game and
I don't want to be another bad statistic
how did you prepare yourself for fame
just looked in the mirror that was one
of my techniques definitely well to G
myself up sometimes if you ever feel you
know down sometimes you look at yourself
and you give yourself positive
affirmations that was something I used
to do every morning but also therapy
after my first UFC fight like straight
after I got home I was like I need to go
see someone about this cuz no way really
I mean like think about it like coffee
you know if you drink coffee right mmm
you get a coffee high and then you crash
so it's like after my first year FC
fight UFC two-to-one in Perth it was
just a lot of stimulus a lot of people
coming at you and when I was finally
home alone with my own thoughts I was
just like it was like a crash he was
like I was sad and all sad for like a
week knows that why am i sad I just made
my UFC debut in spectacular fashion made
50k bonus mm-hmm
I realize this isn't really normal so I
sought the help that I needed to help me
adjust to the life and it wasn't until
um my fourth year see fight that was in
New York
MSG mm-hmm that I felt like after I got
back I was able to integrate back into
like my own life properly without being
in the low yeah no kidding
well I I think it's wonderful that you
were that we're talking about that sort
of thing cuz it is absolutely zero shame
just to check out or Chesham we sit
there say I'm I say you know everyone is
mentally ill but if you don't look after
your mental health mm-hmm just like if
you don't look after your physical
health right you're gonna get physically
ill so you have to be on top of it if no
I don't want to like I say I don't want
to end up like like Britney Spears in
2007 chasing paparazzi with an umbrella
mm-hmm you know do you remember that is
that what you're saying how how I
remember things how old are you I'm 30
now you're 30 30 Israel out of Sanya
here on the Rich Eisen show okay I want
to get into a few items because your
name was in the mouth of Jon Jones as it
always is I mean that's are gonna follow
next [ __ ]
[Music]
Wow
I didn't expect that to be your response
yeah okay he was in he was on Ariel
Helwani show he said three things I want
to take him one at a time let's go give
you the opportunity to respond mm-hm
Jon Jones said these following things
about you quote he's scared today he'll
be scared in 2021 I'm not a men affair
nothing really scares me
um it would in this came for me to say
he's scared it's it's preposterous
because look at what we do for a living
I don't get scared nothing scares me my
mom maybe scares me and she's mad right
but nothing puts me in that kind of
frame so for me he can sit there and
believe what he wants to believe to make
himself feel comfortable but yeah look
what I've done in the last two years and
look at his first two years on the
company look what he's done it's a big
difference so why would you think he
thinks that you're scared
he just has to say whatever he has to
say to make himself feel better about
the position he's in you know he needs
me he's a guy that he's the one calling
me out first cuz he needs me he needs me
to start something else different cuz
he's already been stagnant in his
division he's cleaned it out you know
I'm only getting started
I'm only been here two years and look
what I've done like I said so I said let
me do my work I'm gonna I'm coming I'm
cleaning out my division first and then
I'm gonna step up on wait cuz he hasn't
even he's been in the UFC war ten years
he hasn't even stepped up in weight
mm-hmm I've been here two years
am i 30 I'm gonna step up and wait so
yeah and the process of cleaning out
your division is first time a second guy
you're America's I've I won the belt in
Atlanta right I beat um this guy right
here the mate gone oh look at that
Oh am I scared this is a sec my first
title defense I knocked the guy out
twice in one fight mm-hmm my first title
defense in his backyard so they even he
what his part was about Robert Whittaker
I can't wait till Robert Whittaker
stumps a mud hole in his ass and now
he's saying I can't wait so you're
romero holds him down them smashes him
like they're gonna keep hoping and I
said I don't throw and hope I aim and
fire there's a big difference all right
so here's the fears the second time
John Jones had you Israel Auto Sonia in
his in his mind in his mouth gates used
on Michael Irvin phrase my buddy Michael
I'm a man and he's like a child when it
comes to this game okay boomer I said
that before I say it again and people oh
but he's only a year older than you yeah
boomer is a mindset he is an old
suburban Caucasian man he's not he's not
that we're not the same you know I'm a
young fresh kid on the block I'm the
freshman he's the old senior who's
jealous hmm at the new kid on the block
with the ice doing what you wish you
would have done in his formative years
so if if John Jones is a suburban
Caucasian what does that make me at age
50 with three children your fresher than
him I'll tell you they see the last time
we're on the way we're dancing oh by the
way fresher than him 100%
hundred-percent fresher than him follow
that we should put that out on the Rich
Eisen show on let's make that headline
fresher than John Jones good sips tea
all right here's the third one
mm-hmm quote there's a very likely
chance that you'll Romero would beat him
yeah of course I mean this is a fight
game of course if I didn't do the right
things if I don't drop my eyes and cross
my T's of course he can beat me but this
is this is my fight to win this is my
fight to lose it's a like I said your
honor it's coming off three fight loss
he's coming for three fight loss but
he's a formidable opponent he's a guy of
this era that a lot of people for
whatever reason don't want to fight him
and for me that makes me go why don't
you want to fight him he's just another
man he bleeds he sweats just like you
I've seen him get tired like by the
second round so I know he's a guy that
can be beat and he has been beat and
he's a guy that has on his own tactics a
case tool gate and other things that he
uses to win so I want to be the guy to
beat him in this is his last
at the built-in the Matt I mean he's got
like three or four shots already mm-hmm
this is the last attempt so I know he's
gonna come prepared and I want to be the
guy to take him out and really put him
away Israel out of Sanya here on the
Rich Eisen show so what is I mean we're
dancing around a subject that that I
think John is hitting straight on the
head and so many fans would want to see
what when when next year right a stadium
international fight week of I've set the
date already I've told everyone you did
say I think you said that the last time
because every time I've said something I
said
I'm the UFC middleweight champion from
my UFC debut you just don't know it yet
I did that from my UFC debut and I did
my before my my UFC debut I said I was
gonna fight Robert Whittaker for this
belt in 2019 and I did I said I'm gonna
beat John Jones
20:21 Raiders stadium international
fight week and I will every single time
I say something I always find a way
there's a method to my madness I put it
out there in front of the world so that
way I do everything in my power my
subconscious does everything in its
power to make it happen if not then not
to eat my words and I don't like doing
that you know so I make them eat their
words every single time and he has
multiple times now why again did you
choose Raiders Stadium why did you
assume international fight week last
year right I was in my hotel room and I
could see it being built mm-hmm and I
was just visualizing I was prophesizing
some things and I just decided that's
where it's gonna be that's the biggest
stage I can think of for that particular
fight and he said he wants to fight in
prayer he wants to find most early as
like yeah do that I've already done that
I saw that a stadium right beat that you
know so ray the stadium is the next one
when I find him into the 2021 and what
do we know what the date is can we can
we July July next year
I mean it's wide open I imagine can we
save the date she recalled that's oh no
do we send mark Davis's save the date
card the owner of the Raiders you know
they lock save the date they
cuz they are building it it's it's
opening it looks beautiful it looks like
a glass bowl just a black shiny UFO in
the middle of Las Vegas like an like an
alien spaceship right there look at that
that's the one described look at that
that's the latest odd-looking that's a
spaceship storm I know like the Deaf
just literally just lift off the ground
and blast off but that's beautiful oh I
own that that's mine that's mine
it's done look at that shiny just like
me well your energy will definitely lift
the place off if you're fighting John
Jones in that place July 2021 mmm it'll
be like a hundred million degrees
outside and then inside you would go
down a vision do you even envision how
you do beat him yeah any time how do you
beat him I want to choke him out
I think I'll be fun if I say fee if I
went for if he shot for a takedown yeah
I guillotine him and he tries to roll on
his back then I get on top and he tries
to fight it and then he goes out limp
from being chucked unconscious and her
being stops me and then I Drive my nuts
across his face as I slide off and then
I'm just like yeah Deez Nuts I be
gangsta man don't you think I mean like
you know it was it was it was gangsta
laughter you guillotine him on top and
just slide across his face litter like a
slithering snake right yeah but aren't
you a concern that you're telling him
you're giving him a shot the bleep
friend that I can give him the game plan
boss though beat them any day I give him
all the game plan I told Robert
Whittaker cuz I knew they're gonna try
used the Kelvin Gastelum game plan
against me and rush me I told them don't
do it that was a different Israel you
were you were seeing that was a
different guy
I adjusted within the second run I
adjusted my mistake that he caught me in
the first run I told them so I can give
him the game plan I can give them the
blueprint and I'd still beat them any
day yeah I know you're being serious
about it and the reason why I'm smiling
again we're calling what you said
literally like that led to a classic
dropping of deez nutz Azrael is on you
here would you still fight him if Jon
Jones loses it's not about the belt it's
not about that it's about legacy and I'm
chasing all the big names in this game
every one of them I feel like when it's
all said and done they'll be like man
that guy is he that got Styles he really
he never ducked anyone mm-hmm he never
said no to any fight he chased everyone
down and smashed them he's the goat he's
the one he's the best and everything
he's ever done I can take away like that
mm-hmm
and then I'll add on to my own legacy
cuz I'm not just gonna finish that at
that's it I'm gonna come back down again
and defend my belt
and then I might relinquish the 205 no
if I feel like it even if he doesn't
have the belt like I said it's just
about the history but their heads is
about the the mantelpiece how it's gonna
look by the time everything's all said
and done you put here I mean the pelts
on the wall exactly skin them up line
them up like a nice rug on the fireplace
where do you come up with this stuff did
you just know I feel like a vessel
sometimes I started the game at level
two these boys are still loading like I
feel like a vessel sometimes I'm like
you ever played The Sims No yeah you
know that simulation game man yeah yeah
sometimes you have to wonder what kind
of a hologram we're living in so it's a
different version okay 2.0 I've you know
you're the last style bender we know
that definite okay
all right so what is Romero have in
store for him let's just give you that
out for him and like I said this is his
last shot so I know um
his backs against the wall so he's gonna
come out with everything he's gonna give
everything he might blow his wad you
know in the first two rounds but I know
he's gonna give everything to try and
take this away from me
and I'll do everything in my power to
not let that happen that's why I said
what I want to do so there's the method
to my
I say it and that way my body my mind my
soul will do everything in its power to
ensure that doesn't happen AXS dot-com
tickets are available t mobile arena
March 7th 2024 this on ESPN Plus on
pay-per-view ok get that there go get
that alright
and then and that's and then comes
eventually that fight in in Raiders
stadium yeah I've got a few more fights
before that I like a guy like Paula the
juice monkey Kosta I've got um my gym
what's his name Jarek Hannah near the
crystals Kelvin Gastelum if he can run
up you know the the ranks again that
until they'll go to like the vanilla
gorilla if he um you know it keeps doing
what he does at middleweight I really
want to do right by this belt cuz the
belt has been on hiatus for so long from
the former champion cuz he pulled our
game was really strong so he was always
pulling on the injuries and all that
kind of stuff but I want to make sure
this gets defended a few times and then
like I said I'll jump up to you know do
what I do over there and they come back
down and clean up the division again for
a second time and then see ya adios and
then again I just want to make sure that
the date is saved that there's not like
sort of like rope motocross all set up
or some sort of you know One Direction
concert you know that you know like an
all of a sudden your plan that you've
been hatching like oh it's gonna happen
he told Dana White if your plan I told
ya he knows so I mean they know we
talked sometimes but he knows like he
I'm sure he he the permission gets
relayed back to him so they already know
it and he's gone he can pull strings I'm
sure I mean there's some strings rather
see one-directional you see me kick
Jones's ass in one direction I didn't
mean to put them in the middle of all
this I'm just pulling things off the top
my head here free stuff alright at style
bender on both Twitter and Instagram
Israel out of Sonya you are you're a
blast man thanks for coming on good luck
good luck to you studios welcome for you
and Tom thanks you guys you've got it
Israel honest on you here on the Rich
Eisen
[Applause]
do you have do you have that's that that
the DJ Mikey D that drop that you got
that because he just basically gave that
one out right here yes your boy big
snoop d-o-double-g coming at you live
from Los Angeles and my DJ DJ Mikey D we
are back for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 under red TV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app